a show of force against sri lanka's
president gotabe rajpaksa and his
administration
services were disrupted as thousands of
workers joined a one-day strike
demanding the government's resignation
we are telling the government very
clearly they should heed to the message
of the working class or else it won't
just be one day we will work towards
longer stoppages and paralyze the
country if we have to to chase go to
bayer rajapaksa
teachers dentists postal workers railway
staff and bankers were among the many
thousands of people who stayed away from
work to join colleagues in marches like
this one in colombo
they say they will lend their full
support to the protest movement against
a government they say is inefficient and
corrupt and has only looked after its
own needs not the peoples our system was
political system administrative systems
they are very ineffective ineffective
system you want to change that into a
effective one strikers marched to the
president's office where anti-government
protests entered their 20th consecutive
day on thursday similar marches and
protests were held in each district
bringing striking workers here outside
the main government hospital in chilao
in northwest sri lanka nurses carried a
coffin symbolizing what they say is the
final journey of the present government
train stations were deserted even the
main railway station in colombo the
nerve center for commuters
and bus stops were crowded with people
hopeful they can board the few buses on
the roads
president gotaber rajapaksa and his
government are fighting major battles on
the economic and political fronts
the government has no money to pay for
food medicine fuel and other essential
imports after its foreign reserves fell
to alarming levels
the government is talking to the imf
world bank and friendly countries to
raise emergency funds
but newly appointed finance minister ali
sabri has admitted things will get hard
before they get better union leaders say
today's work stoppage is just a token of
what they can do
they warn that if the government does
not heed paul's to leave
they will launch much worse miner
fernandez al jazeera colombo
[Music]